please welcome Rachel Johnson
yes bricks it is a big part of your job
because you're you you you are in
politics you are in journalism and of
course you have your brother when this
is over
when this is over is it gonna be over
sometime in the future 50 years perhaps
but I mean it has divided Britain in a
way and it it has also divided British
families and and and your family is
really an example it's a micro cosmos I
know in a way I know yes I mean you see
it has divided the family but mainly and
two members who think that brexit is a
idea and those who think it's a
really idea I like to say that yes
yeah you're in a free country now
but you know yes it hasn't it's what
it's divided us all emotionally because
we love our brother I love Boris who I
don't call Boris by the way I call him
Alexander or Al like his close family
call him al how come he changed his name
because okay the story is is when he was
at Eton which is a you know this most
famous public ie private school in the
whole world he was we lived in Brussels
and so he had his passport on lying
around his room ever all the boys have
their own rooms and some other boys
broke into his room and like were
trashing the room and they found the
passport they discovered his name with
Alexander Boris de FEV L Johnson
so they defaced his passport right so
they wrote over de FEV de P P you know
like that's about the way you're
exclusive for tonight I see anyway so
after that they discovered he was called
Boris and you know any English boarding
schools they're always looking for
things to tease are the kids about to
rub the corners off we say you know you
go to school and your parents have loved
you and you've had everything and you
have a lovely duvet and you have hot
chocolate and then you go to boarding
Singlish boarding school and it's
beating and early-morning Greek and
rugby and was it like that for you yeah
totally and I was the first girl at an
English boys boarding school so I really
know before that you you you traveled a
lot I mean you all you all moved around
on yeah the family was really
peripatetic I grew up in we grew up in
Washington in New York and in Brussels
but but I mean you because there's
there's your dad and your mom they're
there they're both life alive
but they are on Boris side right in the
brexit question yes no no no no it's
complicated really complicated my mean
my father led a campaign for
environmentalists for Europe in the
run-up to the vote on June the 23rd he
was a passionate pro-european he spent
his entire life working for European
institutions the European Parliament the
Commission and to do good things you
know to introduce the habitats directive
the waste directive say that we have
clean air and you know mammals have say
have clean environments so today where
is here today well you'll have to ask
him I will I think he's I've listened
this is what I was getting to nothing
nothing nothing that brexit is anything
but a bad idea I'm still
I mean when you're when you're all
together do you have this like
discussions when you because you see
each other like calm it's like you can't
talk about it honestly so what are the
rules then no practice dance no breaks
it will mean a brexit at mealtimes none
no no no so you talk about the weather
or what whatever you say things like
crunch very nice crunchy roast potatoes
so have you seen the Joker or you know
who's watching succession you know this
sort of thing like normal families do so
have you ever had the great discussion
with your brother the argument about of
course I have yeah you know I spent a
whole day trying to persuade him not to
go for the vote leave side before the
referendum and I failed you you have
another brother also he was in the
government as well he was he resigned
from the cabinet over this issue are you
all talking are you all my brother's
been really busy the last three weeks
yeah
he's sorting it out Lee he wants to get
it done I see this bit as like I don't
know a thousand metres of hurdles and if
we get the withdrawal agreement bill
known as the web over the line that's
probably only the first hurdle in a
hundred two hundred hurdles you had this
culture in the family I suspect that you
discuss things um that's an interesting
question my little defenders my father
sent us to boarding school really soon
because he said that parenting was too
important to be left to parents was much
easier if you got the kids and you sent
them to boarding school in another
country so that's what he did to all of
us but all but before that we went to
the European school in Brussels and we
were in the English section the English
national section there and we played
well we fought and played with the Danes
and the Germans and the Swedes in their
different sections but we were educated
in the Europeans well you and your
brother is competitive yes was there a
competitive culture yes
who would win well for example I'll tell
you story if I was but I was once
playing ping pong with the Prime
Minister and he lost one point against
me and he was so angry he kicked the
wall and he broke his toe he's not a
good loser
he's not that's why he's one you know
because you know the spoils go to the
person who wants the most who carry yes
but yeah where does this I mean he can
obviously stand a lot of pressure yeah I
agree I mean I couldn't I couldn't do
this to his job for five minutes I mean
I think what the essential qualities of
being a good Prime Minister to be in
have incredible stamina incredible
energy in crabbit incredible tolerance
for stress and to thrive on very little
sleep and if you read the three-volume
biography of mrs. Thatcher that is he
has those Thatcherite qualities as well
you you say Thatcher are looking at the
family per se I would say it's like a
British Kennedy family you're very kind
but well some people say were the pound
shop Trump's I mean my father loved it
to be the Kennedys but with labour yeah
I was guilty cadavers
because because Francine from abroad
it's all it's all often described as as
some kind of political brothers your
brother and Donald Trump they are some
kind of similar characters on the
political world scene well I heard
somebody told me well you remember of
course what Donald Trump tweeted or he
he said are they like him over there
they call him Britain Trump but then
when I was in Paris the other day I
didn't know that he was cool uppity
tongue you know but can you doesn't be
insulted on his behalf
yes I mean it's I it's really doesn't
make you proud do you think this I'm
incredibly proud that he's achieved his
lifetime ambition I hate it when I see
him being shouted at and you know in the
street or people being rude about him
because I'm I care about him as a as a
sibling you know it hurts me like it I
can't explain it it hurts me in my you
know soul but I don't like the politics
of what's going on either so I sit her
every day as I guess a schizophrenic
nightmare but you said a lifetime
ambition was it when was the first time
you realized this was his lifetime
ambition when he was about four years
old he he told her family friend he
wanted what whether he was asked what
would you like to be when you grew up
and he said world king would you say he
had the support of his family all the
way sure yeah I mean definitely his
parents yes so there are four of us he's
young and um I think if you're the
oldest of four and very tight family and
very close together in age I'm only two
fourteen months younger than him and
then I have a brother Leo's two years
younger than me and then there's Joe
who's like a little bit younger I think
you know he felt he had to move very
fast and break break things to do what
he wanted to do because everyone else
was chasing at one point you decided
not only to be to be a remainder as you
as you are obviously are but you decided
to to go for to actually go for a seat
in the European Parliament I know for
the remainders and I wonder how how did
you tell your brother that there's
always been a we've always had a
principle in the family that everybody
has to be free you know to have their
own sovereignty and nobody can be
controlled by somebody else just because
they're older or more powerful that's
why you can sit here tonight yeah of
course everybody has to be free and even
if he doesn't like it he has to accept
that he's free I'm free everyone is free
and we you know we have to pay the
consequences if we say things that
actually undermine him or unfair but
apart from that I think politically we
have to be able to express ourselves but
still it's and we did phone call today
isn't it I texted him I just got a text
back saying good luck
which in fact I really need it because I
didn't make it it's a brutal environment
in Britain around it's really tough it's
really tough there's so much unhappiness
and so much tension and boredom we're so
bored I mean just I really sometimes
feel if there was another referendum
okay
instead of saying the brexit lot will
say tell them again I would say my pitch
would be make it stop okay if you could
be the party which would tell the entire
country if you voted for us it would
stop and actually that would be to stay
in the EU because then nothing would
have to change we're and have to talk
about trade for the next 20 years
the leaders of the brexit lot and the
government have stopped saying anything
about what's going to be good after we
leave the EU all they say is the people
have spoken
Parliament has got to do what the people
said three and a half years ago as if
democracy stopped and was frozen like in
amber and for one night only
that was democracy in this country tell
me how do you like it in in number ten
how do you think it is there I mean I've
never been there and there's something I
haven't been since he's been Prime
Minister you haven't been there so he
hasn't invited you no I'm just being
honest I'm very honest for I have been
to the country place which is very nice
checkers so you've been there I've been
there yeah okay so it's not it's not
that they don't want you in this I think
you'll have to ask him
wonderful to get the Prime Minister and
ask him but I he's been there so busy
and also if I went into number ten
there's all the petition exactly not for
me but for everybody who goes in and out
but there's a back entrance you know you
can go in through the Cabinet Office at
the back do you think that in in one
year this time next year do you think
you're still the prime minister's sister
I think yes I think probably I think the
country is very behind the Prime
Minister and I think the country is
unbelievably fatigued by this let's say
I want to go and move to Paris and work
in Paris I can't know you know so no
wonder the prime minister says Britain's
gonna be the greatest place on earth
well that's the only place that I'm
gonna be around to be
wonderful to have you on the show we're
gonna have a guest okay thank you thank
you Rachel don't hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe
you